okay so today we've got a little
mathematical nugget for you I'm going to
talk about 10 factorial so 10 factorial
is what you get when you multiply the
numbers 10 times 9 times 8 times 7 I'm
gonna go all the way down times 2 times
how big is 10 factorial on your
calculator you will find a little button
with an exclamation mark after it there
we go that is how big 10 factorial is
let's write this down three million six
hundred and twenty eight thousand eight
hundred now what I want to talk about is
10 factorial seconds now how long is 10
factorial seconds right so three million
six hundred twenty eight thousand eight
hundred second how long is that well it
turns out to be exactly six weeks let me
show you got 10 factorial seconds so how
many minutes is that there are 60
seconds in a minute and so I'm going to
divide by 60 60 is 10 times 3 times 2
that's the way I'm going to do it so I'm
going to divide by 60 I can just count
it out 10 and 3 and 2 that's a way to
divide by 60 I can might as well cancel
out the 1 as well while I'm at it how
many hours is that I'm going to divide
by 60 again another way to write 60 is 5
times 4 times 3 that also equals 60 I'm
going to cancel out the 5 and the 4 and
I want to come till 3 I don't have it
I'm going to take the 9 divided by 3 so
that now becomes a 3 instead this is how
many minutes we've got how many hours is
that I want to divide by 24 24 is 8
times 3 and divide by 8 and up now
disappears fantastic 24 is gone so this
is how many hours it is how many weeks
is that there are seven days in a week
on divide by seven
that's how many weeks it is how many
weeks is it what's left six though are
sit exactly six weeks for 10 factorial
seconds exactly so if you're at school
and if you're looking forward to your
six weeks holiday in it or it doesn't
see night long enough well
perhaps you might like to think of it as
your 10 factorial second holiday so
let's try this from the other direction
so how many seconds are there in six
weeks so we got six weeks how many days
is that how many days are there in six
weeks we're going to times by seven
seven days in a week how many hours is
that 24 hours in a day so we're going to
times by 24
how many as minutes is that well that's
times by 60 60 minutes in an hour and
then times by 60 again because there's
60 seconds in a minute this is how many
seconds you get in six weeks now we get
our calculator let's see if we do get
what I said it was going to be six weeks
times seven days times 24 hours times 60
minutes times 60 seconds is exactly what
I said before
three million at six hundred twenty
eight thousand eight hundred or to put
it another way 10 factorial